even Nick I do think you're honorable
man but what you forgetting is that all
these sensors are in place because you
put cameron into number 10 it didn't
have a majority so there will be no work
program nowhere near as many benefits
sanctions then you could have made a
different choice and that's why people
don't trust you people like me that
voted for you in the election did not
vote liberal democrat what camry number
10 yeah but what explain what did what
did you expect what did you want I'm
sorry what did you want at my preference
would have been for him to have
continued negotiations with with labor
which I think a lot of Liberal Democrat
natural voters are can I in voter labor
that protested but can I just make
there's just a little matter of
democracy you could've chosen no no you
did choose no that is not accept
responsibility you did choose that was
your choice come on that's not actually
the case after the last election no one
won a majority whether you all I like it
or not the Liberal Democrats did not win
I'm not prime minister I lead a party of
eight percent of MPs in the House of
Commons and it was the Conservatives
that one the most votes in seat great
team and a slugging each other off can I
David Cameron says you were a great team
and night night or slightly ensure that
off now you keeps keeps talking about
darkened rooms as does that Miliband I
have to say too if either of them still
think they're going to win a majority
they need to go and lie down in that
darkened room but look though the point
the point the point I want to make that
point like to make to you into everybody
is this is